[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER 1: Shanghai GDG
is a very interesting
developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER 2: This is
when magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: This is
primarily a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions?
JENNY MURPHY: Hello everyone.
Welcome to this week's session
of the Google+
Platform Office Hours.
Whoops.
I accidentally had
my sound on.
Sorry about that.
Welcome to the Google+ Platform
Office Hours.
This is the show where we keep
you up-to-date with what's new
on the Google+ platform.
This week, we're going to be
talking about the new release
of the Hangouts API, version
1.2, but before we get into
that, let me introduce myself
and my co-host, and those
developers who have joined in.
So I'm Jennifer Murphy.
I'm a developer programs
engineer here at Google.
I focus on Google+, and I help
you build awesome stuff with
our APIs and plug-ins.
And joining me in-studio today,
our Hangout expert.
JONATHAN BERI: Jonathan Beri.
I'm a developer advocate
working on Google+.
I spend a lot of my time
building Hangout apps and
doing video conferencing.
Fun stuff.
And I worked a little
bit on this release.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
And joining us through
the magic of
cyberspace on the Hangout.
From left to right,
we have Allen.
And I think you might
be muted.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: I'm an
outside developer, and I do
most of my work with
the Hangout API.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
Gerwin.
GERWIN STURM: Hi, I'm
Gerwin from Austria.
I'm a developer doing all sorts
of stuff with different
Google+ APIs.
JENNY MURPHY: Thanks.
And Moritz.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Hi.
I'm Moritz from Germany, and
I'm a system engineer and I
work mostly with the Hangouts
API, the Google+ API, and some
other cool APIs from Google
to [? Google Maps. ?]
JENNY MURPHY: Thanks for
joining us, guys.
And so I guess we'll
get right into it.
So, Jonathan, what's new in the
version 1.2 release of the
Hangouts API?
JONATHAN BERI: So 1.2 is
our latest release.
And we've been iterating on some
of the name-spaces that
we launched in the beginning.
Sort of rounding it
out, we added a
few general API features.
Some are interesting if you have
particular use cases, but
some are just, we felt like
we needed to add them.
Things like the Topic.
So Get Topic, On Topic
Change kind of stuff.
Locale information, if the
Hangout has a particular
preferred language
for the speakers.
Things around the YouTube
live-streams to
get to YouTube live.
But sort of the bigger releases
are new types of
sound effects.
So previously, we allowed you
to broadcast locally.
So I could hear-- let's say it's
my turn-- like a ding,
for example.
But in the newest release, we've
added the ability to
broadcast sound, so everybody
can hear that same track.
Whether it be background
music playing in a
game or a laugh track.
It's all synchronized, and it
uses the same noise canceling
capabilities of the plug-in.
And you just have to pass
that URL and it plays.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
JONATHAN BERI: We've also
released another interesting
API related to an app we produce
called Cameraman.
And so we provide the ability
for broadcast applications to
remove particular users
from the broadcast.
JENNY MURPHY: That sounds
really useful for larger
broadcasts.
JONATHAN BERI: But by far, I
think the most requested
feature that we made into 1.2
is our memory management
capabilities.
This is the ability to load
resources to the plug-in,
whether they be static
overlays or
face-tracking overlays.
And really know when they're
loaded, to dispose of them
when you don't need them, to
track one that's actually been
disposed, and events
around that stuff.
So I would like to spend a few
minutes just talking about
those particular features in
a little bit more depth.
And general best practices
for memory management.
JENNY MURPHY: Sounds great.
Tell us more.
JONATHAN BERI: So, before
1.2, you could
create a new resource.
And that could be an image
resource, that could be an
audio resource.
And you just kept on creating
them as you needed them.
There was actually no way to
dispose of those resources.
So the challenge was, every
time you create a new
resource, you take up memory,
and the plug-in runs--
whether it be an image
or an audio snippet--
in the memory of the browser
and in your system.
And it varies across different
capabilities of systems.
So high-end machines would have
lots of memory to play
around with, and lower-end
machines would just bork out.
So of course we want to address
that problem by adding
the ability to not only track
when resources are loaded, but
to figure out the state
of all the resources
and dispose of them.
So that same face-tracking or
static overlay or even audio
resource, you can properly
manage them.
And that really helps you if
you're trying to be nice to
your users' computers.
Or if you're trying to use
those resources for more
computationally intensive
things.
And it's pretty neat.
If you go to the
documentation--
I'm not going to actually pull
up or walk through the
particular examples-- but on the
actual objects you create,
you can go ahead and call
Method, call Dispose, and that
will get rid of it.
You can also check if it's
loaded by calling Is-Loaded
Method or Is-Disposed Method.
And there's a bunch of events
associated with the different
types of objects to tell
when it's loaded.
So you can track that.
And you can go ahead and sort
of walk through all your
different objects or your
resources, in this case, and
dispose of them or
work with them.
JENNY MURPHY: Very cool.
So sounds like it opens
up potential for new
applications?
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah,
definitely.
So we have a set of running
sample apps.
And our go-to sample app
is the media-Starter.
And that plays around
with different
use cases for overlays.
One example that we
added recently was
the ability to do--
we're calling it an animated
overlay-- but really, it has a
little counter with a clock that
changes from zero to one,
to two, to three.
And that does that efficiently
by disposing of it when it's
not necessary.
So playing around with
the different URLs.
JENNY MURPHY: Very cool.
Sounds like a lot of potential
for some pretty cool overlay
applications, so I
look forward to
seeing what people develop.
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah.
And it just goes in line with
the larger topic of memory
management.
As front-end engineers, we tend
not to worry about memory
management the same way that
other types of engineers.
So if you've come from an
embedded system background or
building console games, you very
much know that memory is
really important.
But in the client-side world,
we tend not to build really
resource-intensive applications
unless you're
really into game space.
But when you're doing things
with Hangouts, you are
starting to create resource
constraints.
So taking advantage of the
ability to dispose of
resources or smartly reusing
those is best practices.
But also things like
taking advantage of
requestAnimateFrame, which is
a feature of the browser, to
smartly change your frame rate,
and tab visibility,
which lets you know if a user's
currently focused on
your application,
and things like
Web-Workers and Smart caching.
Things like that.
JENNY MURPHY: Very cool.
Excellent.
So thanks for that summary of
what's new in Hangouts 1.2.
JONATHAN BERI: You're welcome.
JENNY MURPHY: So as I said
during the pre-roll, this is a
questions and answer show.
Does anyone from the Hangout
have any questions about
things we added in the version
1.2 API or anything else about
Hangout app development?
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Yeah, I had
a question that is actually a
follow-up a little bit on the
memory resource issues that we
just discussed.
One of the things that people
have noticed is that once you
have an image resource, you can
create a single overlay
from that, but trying to create
a second overlay, or
trying to create another image
resource using the same URL
doesn't work as well as
you might expect.
Is that still an
issue with 1.2?
JONATHAN BERI: There was a
threat actually with Moritz
regarding that.
It's sounded like there was a
bug with using the same URL.
But not creating
new resources.
So in general, go ahead and
intelligently create a new
resource when you want
to have a new image.
But, for example, in the Lower
Thirds use case, you really
only have one image resource,
so you want to swap out the
URL if it changes.
And the bug is filed, and
that particular one is
being worked on.
And I don't think there should
be any issues with creating
new image resources.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: OK.
I think this actually came up
with the donut tossing game.
Where they wanted to have
multiple donuts, which were
the same image resource, but
multiple overlays from that.
And their workaround at the time
was actually to create
multiple image resources.
JONATHAN BERI:Yep, yep.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: OK, so
that's still in place.
That constraint is
still there.
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah.
That's actually a bug.
And that's being worked
on as we speak.
It's already been filed
and identified.
But creating new resources just
in general shouldn't be
any problem.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: OK.
JONATHAN BERI: If you look at
just the effects app, for
example, we're using multiple
overlays with face-tracking
overlays, so there's three to
four overlays at one time.
There's no problem there.
Cool.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Yeah, I just
want to jump in right there.
As Gerwin mentioned, there's
still a bug with the same
image resource when the
URL is the same.
I noticed that a while ago, it
was working fine in version
1.1, but at some point,
something changed in the
Hangout code which is causing
this issue, this
behavior, of the URL.
So whenever I have a Lower
Third up and disable it
without changing anything and
want to load it up again, it's
not showing up.
But now with version 1.2 and
with the Dispose Method, I can
handle these images in my app.
So whenever I disable an
overlay, I dispose
it at the same time.
But as you said, if you want
to load up the same URL, so
more than one object, like
cloning them, it's not working
at the moment.
JONATHAN BERI: Right.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: If you dispose
any resources and
handle the resources properly
with the new methods, it's
working fine.
JONATHAN BERI: Great.
Yeah, it's a great workaround.
And like I said, it may be in
the plug-in level, so that's
something that changed
over time.
And we basically may have
reintroduced that minor bug,
but it's an easy fix and we've
identified it, so that
shouldn't be a problem.
And--
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Yeah,
another workaround--
sorry--
JONATHAN BERI: No, go for it.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Another
workaround I figured so far is
to just add a transparent pixel
somewhere in the image
and change the alpha channel
always in one step.
So the data URL is always a bit
different, but you don't
actually see it in
the actual image.
So it's some sort of tricky
workaround until it gets
fixed, and this works as well.
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah, and I
think one of those other
solutions that we talked about
was if you know the image is
not changing, you may not
need to dispose of it.
You may just want to hide it,
and then re-enable it at a
future time.
And if there is a change to the
resource, you may want to
use things like fragment
identifiers to change the URL,
cache-busting style.
But of course, there's still
the bug that we're going to
plug as well.
But that may come in handy for
other instances when you want
to have the same base image
resource and to do things like
data URIs to dynamically
change that content.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
So if you are watching the
stream live, either on YouTube
or on Google+ Developers, I just
want to remind you that
you are welcome to ask
questions, either by posting
on the event as a comment
or by commenting
on the YouTube channel.
I'm watching the comments right
here, so feel free to
ask questions.
So does anyone in the Hangout
have any other questions about
the API before we
move on to the
questions from the comments?
JONATHAN BERI: Gerwin, I'm going
to ask you a question.
I saw a comment about the
YouTube Live ID, and that
you've integrated it into one
of your applications?
GERWIN STURM: No, not yet.
I am planning to.
JONATHAN BERI: Oh.
Do you want to talk about it?
GERWIN STURM: Yeah, so I'm
planning to use it for the
Comment Tracker because then
people can just start up the
Comment Tracker, and I can
automatically fetch all the
YouTube comments without people
having to copy the URL
and putting it in.
So just to make it easier for
people to use Comment Tracker
so they don't have to copy a URL
from here, from there, to
just take it and put it in.
So to just start the Comment
Tracker and we'll fetch the
YouTube ID automatically and
fetch all the comments.
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah so
I kind of glazed
over that minor feature--
basically again the YouTube Live
of the Hangouts On Air.
That's a perfect use case
of that functionality.
Because right now, the
broadcaster, the Hangout, does
have the embed code, for
example, for the YouTube, but
can't interact with it.
So there's a lot of interesting
use cases of how
you could use the YouTube URL
right in your application for
broadcast purposes, sharing,
and things like that.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
It seems like it'll make
a lot of things easier.
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah,
definitely.
JENNY MURPHY: Definitely.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Jonathan, can
you just mention briefly,
is the data that is returned
by that the ID
of the YouTube video?
Or is it a URL for one
of the various ways
to get to that video?
JONATHAN BERI: It is
the YouTube ID.
And so you can essentially
generate the YouTube URL by
appending the ID to
the YouTube.com.
GERWIN STURM: And so I actually
wanted to ask about--
because we have this on YouTube
ID ready event.
Will this fire in any case, or
if we already have Hangout
On-Air running and then start
the application later, will
the event still fire?
Because then the ID
was already ready?
Do you need to check
this, or will the
event fire in any case?
JONATHAN BERI: That's
a good question.
I haven't tested for that, but
that's sort of something I
could figure out for you.
GERWIN STURM: Yeah, that's
probably something I'm going
to test anyways.
JONATHAN BERI: OK, we'll
do that in conjunction.
GERWIN STURM: I'll
let you know.
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah, there are
some cases where the events
will fire in only one
rare situation.
But it's still useful.
So for example, on some of the
Hangouts, the on-air stuff,
will only fire in one
particular path.
So we still provide those
because that one use case it's
useful for.
So say apps we're building
or apps that we foresee.
JENNY MURPHY: Although for an
[? on ready ?], I'd expect it
to probably work for when
participants join.
So give it a try and tell
us how well it works.
If the current behavior is not
what you expect, we can always
take another look at it.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: OK, I have not
really two questions, but
more like feature requests
or suggestions.
JENNY MURPHY: I love feedback.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: One
thing I already
talked about with Jenny.
It would be cool to be able to
figure with the API if the
Hangout is set to
plus 18 or not.
Because I'm working on a game
currently which might contain
some swear words
in one edition.
So we want to build
like two editions.
One which is PG-13 and one which
is 18 plus, but this
requires me to have some tools
in the API where I can figure
out the state of the Hangout by
is it public or not or is
it 18 plus or not.
And the other thing is,
especially I think for all
developers who develop apps,
I haven't tried it yet, but
would it work when I add a +1
button to my app, or like the
Share button, would it actually
share the app?
Am I able to put specific URL
stuff in there, including the
app ID so they can launch the
app from the shared host?
Or is that something you could
probably think of building
into the API, like having
a share option for apps?
JENNY MURPHY: I can
answer that one.
So yes, you can render Share
buttons, +1 buttons, badges,
and all those plug-ins
within a Hangout.
And you can specify
target URLs.
So you can render a +1 button
and you can target
whatever you like.
You could target the
URL to start the
Hangout, for example.
But if you're going to be
changing the target often and
during the runtime of your
Hangout, potentially if you're
targeting a high score or some
other content like that--
the Share link might actually
be the most appropriate.
Because it's the most
light-weight mechanism of
sharing to Google+.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Yeah.
I was actually sharing
the app.
Like when the user opens up the
app and thinks, wow, this
is a great app, I want to share
that with my friends.
Actually they have to figure
out the app or find an app
page to this app.
But when they have a Share
button, they can instantly
click it and it will post to the
Google+ stream, and they
can let other users know
about this app.
JONATHAN BERI: So I've
actually done some
experiments with this.
I have a sample app I should
probably publish, but the code
is really simple.
Because all the plug-ins have
an explicit render mode.
So you can use that to say,
I want to render this
plug-in right now.
And of course the Share link
is a great option.
And we also have the
Hangout URL.
So with the Hangout URL, that's
one way to pass it.
I know some of the Hangout apps
now, like the poker, for
example, they pull in the
hangout URL and they post that
to their site.
And that's one way of doing
it, to share it.
And the other one is to create
a Hangout with a
G ID on it as well.
And it works exactly
as documented.
There's nothing tricky there.
But one thing I also want to
throw in there is brands
really like to use both the
Share link and the Badge
inside their Hangout.
So you can imagine if you're a
brand and you have a Plus Page
and it's really active.
To get users, to drive them to
your Plus Page, the Badge.
As well as share, let's say, the
page, or part of the app.
So it could be a screenshot that
you've rendered or some
sort of stated information.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Talking about
brands, when will it be
able for brands to launch
apps in a Hangout?
I hear a lot of brand page users
and they want use Lower
Third in their brand Hangouts,
but they're not able to
because the permission
thing pops up but
then disappears again.
JONATHAN BERI: Yes.
We did one small change recently
about how extensions
are being rendered
within Hangouts.
I think you saw that post.
And we're working on better
integration for the rest of
Google+ like Plus pages.
So that's coming soon.
And we know it's
a major issue.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: On the
previous topic, I would also
add that I've been doing some
testing recently using the
History API to log when you
start an application and have
that application automatically
show up in your history vault.
And that's been working out
fairly well so far.
Still not production yet, but
it's a good trend and I see
that as a really good avenue
to start pursuing.
JONATHAN BERI: That's
pretty neat.
And actually I think Moments
within a Hangout app could be
interesting too.
That just launched.
JENNY MURPHY: Definitely.
We've gotten a lot of feedback
from many of you and a lot of
other people in the developer
community about Moment ideas,
and a lot of them centered
around the kind of experience
you would expect within
a Hangout app.
So we're listening.
Keep the feedback coming, all
you, to continue that
development for sure.
Great.
JONATHAN BERI: Awesome.
JENNY MURPHY: So I guess I'm
going to take a few questions
from the stream.
First one is one I'll field.
Sean asks, will this Hangout be
archived for later viewing?
The answer is yes.
You will always be able to watch
this Hangout from the
Google+ event.
And we'll embed the
video there.
And we'll also upload
it to YouTube, the
Google Developers channel.
I'll include links to that
in the show notes.
So yes, you can watch these.
They'll be archived.
And you can also see all of the
previous sessions archived
there as well.
And Darrell has some
questions.
So Darrell asks, is there a
way for a user to remove a
plug-in from their Hangout
once they have added it?
JONATHAN BERI: And so I think
what Darrell is asking about
for Hangout app extensions, if
somebody ran a Hangout app
extension, can they remove it
during the session and after
the session.
So during the session, you can
actually stop running any app
by going to the lower
app switcher.
There's the People tab
and the Apps tab.
And if you click on that,
you'll see the running
Hangouts, and as you hover over
those apps, there's a
little title and an
X next to it.
And that actually kills the app
for your session, and you
can either run it again if
something went wrong, or if
you just don't want
anymore apps to be
running for this Hangout.
In terms of post Hangout.
So, if you notice at the top the
screen, there's a list of
recently used apps.
And if you go to Add Apps,
there's even a longer one.
That's basically just
a running list.
It's not installed, it's been
recently run and authorized.
Now if you want to de-authorize
that, just like
any app you've ever associated
with your Google account, you
can go to the Google
Account settings
and revoke that access.
But it will still show up in
your Recently Used list.
That's just sort of a UI
feature right now, and
something certainly
we can look into.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
He has a couple more
questions.
So his next question is, the
self view of the camera is
mirrored, flipped
left to right.
This also happens when images
are displayed with my plug-in.
Is this a known issue?
JONATHAN BERI: So that actually,
it's not an issue.
It's something that we've
implemented on purpose.
And it can be a little
confusing.
We actually did a bunch of user
studies around video and
we found that it's actually
awkward for users to see
themselves right facing.
Because in their day-to-day
lives, the only time they
themselves is in a mirror.
And when you display themselves
right facing, it
throws them off.
Their depth perception is kind
of screwed, they don't know
their right from their
left, and this was
through user testing.
And we've enforced that.
And it seems to be helping a
lot with user confusion.
Now when you have an app that
becomes most apparent when you
have text, for example, because
it looks flipped.
When your face is on camera,
it's not as big of a deal.
I've seen even Moritz's app
declare, hey, don't worry,
this is a flipped image, this is
supposed to happen, it will
look right for you.
And that's just something we
have to contend with being on
broadcasting video.
JENNY MURPHY: Right.
Because since we're flipping the
image of yourself, we also
have to flip any overlays you
have so that they line up
properly with whatever the
content on the screen is.
Because if we didn't, content
on the overlay that would be
on the left side would be on the
right side, and you'd have
a different view than those
viewing your stream.
So just a necessary evil, just
part of human psychology.
So we did it on purpose.
If you want to try it out the
other way, you can always use
other web cam applications.
And you should try it
out sometime if
you have the chance.
Using Photo Booth, you can
actually tell it to remove the
reverse and it's a pretty
trippy experience.
You'll definitely realize
why we're doing it if
you try that app.
Darrell has one more question.
I'd love to see the API support
multiple cameras on a
single machine.
Give developers functions to
switch between these cameras
and maybe grab a still
from the camera.
It would add a lot
of functionality.
JONATHAN BERI: So sounds
like there's
three feature requests.
One is to support multiple
cameras from the plug-in.
The second one is expose the
ability to switch those
cameras from the plug-in.
And a third is a
screenshot API.
The multiple cameras one, that
is an interesting challenge.
The way that the Google Talk
plug-in works, is it talks to
the operating system.
Sort of blindly.
Saying, hey I would like a web
cam interface to work and do
some cool stuff with it.
And the operating system's like,
hey, here's the web cam.
It doesn't know too much about
the architecture of the web
cam, it doesn't know the model,
doesn't know the make,
except for a string for
the title to display.
So that's sort of transparent
to the plug-in
as it stands today.
For operating systems that
support multiple web-cams
running at the same time--
and that they can expose
that to the plug-in--
that's a little bit tricky.
Definitely when you move up to
sort of the professional grade
video mixing stuff, the kind of
stuff we use to do this, it
becomes easier.
But for the average consumer
sitting in their house or
maybe at a party using a laptop,
that's probably not
the most common use case.
It's something interesting.
And we're always exploring
different ways you can add new
functionality to the plug-in
beyond just overlays and
broadcasting.
And I think that is an
interesting use case.
I don't have anything else to
say about that today, just
because it is a challenge
in many, many ways.
But the same goes with the API
that would go with that to do
camera switching.
I've definitely seen people
experiment with using multiple
machines and multiple
cameras to do a faux
studio like set up.
So they actually take one of the
spots in the Hangout, and
then use the Hangout app to
switch who's the camera being
focused on.
So you get that sort
of studio effect.
And then the screenshot one is
a great idea, a great feature
request I definitely hope
you can file that
into our issue tracker.
Because I've heard that before,
and if it's not there
already, that's a great
one to bubble up.
JENNY MURPHY: I believe that
one's already being tracked in
our issue tracker, so I'll
include a link to that issue
if you'd like to give some more
feedback or star it, so
you get notified when there's
an update to that request.
So yes, if you have other
requests, please definitely
add them to our issue tracker.
It's the best way for us to
hear about the requests.
It kind of helps us collaborate
and just make sure
we don't lose them
in the shuffle.
So I'll link to the issue
tracker in the
show notes as well.
But thanks a lot for the
feedback and questions.
We have another question
from the stream.
Actually it's more a request.
And I'm about to butcher
your first name,
sorry ahead of time.
Lasse asks, I have
a feature request
for the Hangout button.
It would be really nice to be
able to pre-fill the dialogue
with emails.
So that when the Hangout starts,
it's easier for people
to invite the people that
are maybe connected
to them on the site.
JONATHAN BERI: So first, I
think you got that right.
Lasse is one of the developers
from Symphonical, one of the
apps that are featured.
So yeah, that is a
great request.
We've heard others like the
ability to pre-populate, for
example, members from your
circle or circles.
Right now one of the limitations
to that is the
Hangout button is not JavaScript
based, and exposing
emails through a URL, there's
complicated privacy concerns
both here and around the world,
but I definitely think
we want to make that
button better.
It is a cool feature of
Hangouts-- the ability to
launch a new Hangout with an app
running, and the ability
to launch a new Hangout with
an app running and
pre-populate data.
So I think that's a natural
evolution of where we want to
go is make that button smarter
and stay tuned for that
[INAUDIBLE].
JENNY MURPHY: Yep, it's
definitely something we're
working on.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: I think as
an extension of that, one of
the other things that would be
great is to have the option so
that when it launches, it
doesn't bring up the
invitation window.
So that you can launch into a
Hangout with the app running,
and have the app itself
do invitation via
other magical means.
And not feel like you need
to invite people in
order to run the app.
JONATHAN BERI: Yeah,
that makes sense.
I like that idea.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, these are
both good ideas, and I can see
them both being useful for
different kinds of
applications, perhaps.
Because some applications may
only make sense if there are
people there at the
very beginning.
So a lot of options for
us to consider.
But yes, keep that feedback
coming, we love it.
Great.
So are there
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Oh, you beat me to it--
I was about to ask
if you had--
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: I have another
small feature request.
Are you planning at some point
maybe to enable the API to
expose some data from the
Hangout to external websites,
for example?
I mean only if the Hangout
is public.
For limited Hangout,
no go at all.
But if you have a public
Hangout, it would be cool to
have an API feature which
enables me to give a callback
to another script or something
where I can get a list of
participants who was actually in
the Hangout or who work in
the Hangout--
especially with Hangouts On
Air when I embed the live
player on my own website.
And then I want to display, as
well, the participants below
the post, so people can actually
click on the person
and check out their profiles.
This would be a great feature.
You can ultimately gather a
list, over time, of people who
were in your Hangout shows.
JONATHAN BERI: So basically
either a RESTful API or JSONP
type of interface for metadata
around the Hangouts.
MORITZ TOLXDORFF: Right.
JONATHAN BERI: We don't have
any plans right now.
I've definitely heard that
from you before and from
Hangout Canopy folks who are
trying to do some interesting
things with the RESTful API.
We did sort of a lightweight
thing with Search.
You can sort of trick
Search to find
publicly running Hangouts.
But nothing official in the
Hangouts API namespace.
But definitely useful,
definitely cool.
I like that idea a lot.
And I could think of a bunch
of use cases, especially on
the on-air side of why
we'd use that.
So we'll take that feedback.
JENNY MURPHY: Yes.
Making the REST APIs more
expressive and more
descriptive is something that's
definitely on our radar
and we care a lot about.
So no promises yet, but it's
something we're definitely
thinking about in regard to
Hangouts, events, and other
kinds of rich content
that shows up in the
RESTful APIs today.
Excellent.
So are there any other
questions from
people in the Hangout?
JONATHAN BERI: Is there anything
on the YouTube
channel, by any chance?
JENNY MURPHY: Took a
look at it also.
I think we're pretty much
done for today.
JONATHAN BERI: Cool.
JENNY MURPHY: So thanks a lot
to all of you who tuned in
from YouTube Live from
the Google+ event.
Thanks to everyone who joined in
the Hangout and in-person.
So that's it for this week's
session of the Google+
Platform Office Hours.
We'll be back next
week with another
exciting session, I guess.
JONATHAN BERI: Great.
JENNY MURPHY: Yep,
bye everyone.
JONATHAN BERI: See ya.
[MUSIC PLAYING]